all elections important
we know in our bones this one is more
consequential
this is the most important election in
the history of our country
[Music]
from bloomberg quick take i'm ever white
welcome to the episode six of the most
important election
ever after a summer of protests over
racial injustice and police brutality
the us has had a reckoning of sorts with
just one of the many cultural issues
dividing it
from lgbtq plus and women's rights to
the fate of immigration policy
to the widening rift between the haves
and have-nots here to discuss
all of those cultural and identity
flashpoints how trump and biden relate
to them
and how all of this figures into the
2020 election is rebecca greenfield
a bloomberg news reporter and editor
covering diversity and work culture
and host of bloomberg's the paycheck
podcast rebecca thanks for joining us on
the most important election ever how
goes it
thanks for having me i'm like everyone
else okay
making it just turned on the days to
election and
um yeah just making it through the
pandemic well
six days left or uh seven days left if
if you're counting the
today um first things first rebecca have
you voted yet
and if if not when are you planning to
vote yes yesterday
the person giving me the flu shot asked
me this if i had voted yet so i felt
very ashamed that i haven't
voted yet there's early voting here in
new york where i live and
i was deterred by the long line so i may
actually just end up going in in person
and voting
on voting day but i do plan on making it
to the polls
well i'm sure you're not the only um
american or new yorker who's planning to
do the exact same thing but let's let's
jump right in um rebecca let's set the
stage for our viewers
2020 has been a year of continued strife
over cultural issues particularly race
ethnicity and gender could you describe
some of these flash points leading into
the 2020 election
yeah so 2020 has been a unique year
for sure in the last four years which
have felt very different than the
previous
you know eight years and i think leading
into the election
the biggest flash point that i can think
of has definitely been
the black lives matter protests um of
the late spring and summer have
definitely been
a pivotal point for our country a huge
civil rights movement but also have
figured pretty prominently in the
debates in the election it's something
that
has come up in the debates in something
that both
donald trump and joe biden are running
on in very different ways
um donald trump has definitely
positioned
protesters and city unrest is something
that he
you know needs to save us from and um
talks about the the anarchists on you
know
and there being both sides to the
violence um
whereas joe biden who also definitely
also says that the violence is not a
good thing
he um is more um
sympathetic to the protesters certainly
so i think that has been kind of like
the big lead up i think cities city
violence
um urban unrest um anyway
it's been a huge talking point for both
candidates
um i think the question that a lot of
people ask me is how
motivating is that for voters since
there are so many other issues
on the ballot wow so you touched on a
lot of different points there um
specifically in terms of um how it's
going to affect voters and and the ways
that trump and biden
are sort of handling these tensions and
i mean it's no secret that a lot of
these flashpoints
have had trump his administration his
policies
in the middle of them at some point how
how has the trump administration
handled some of these tensions from the
black lives matter protest to just
police brutality in general
yeah um so i think
their people think that donald trump has
inflamed
the racial tensions um i think
he you know in the first protest against
joe biden one of the standout moments
was when
um chris wallace the moderator asked if
donald trump would
you know say that white supremacy is bad
and donald trump
kind of pushed to further say it's bad
had this moment where he's talking about
the proud boys and who's which is a
white supremacist group and how the
proud boys have to kind of stand down
and stand by so
people see comments like that which is
something the president has made
throughout his presidency
um as you know not bringing the country
together not denouncing
white supremacy not is more like fanning
the flames of these tensions which we
are seeing boil over in cities across
the country
and sometimes in violent ways um and
deadly ways so
i think that certainly that's that's
been donald trump's kind of
orientation to this movement so you
mentioned
trump fanning some of these flames what
other um
situations has trump in your opinion
um you fan the flames of um in terms of
cultural issues
yeah the one that i was thinking about
this really comes to mind which
you know i think um the emboldening of
white supremacists in the last four
years has really been
a huge issue and when i think of that i
think of the charlottesville
um protests so and donald trump
saying that there were very fine people
on both sides i think that was a
defining moment of his presidency
and another moment where it was
seen as signaling to these white
supremacist groups who do support donald
trump
um and again was a violent protest and
and um you know images of those protests
protests and white supremacists marching
in the streets of charlottesville i
think
really were resonated with people and
and changed
the way we see our country um so
that's a good point you mentioned the
the protests and charlottesville sort of
showing the ugly face of of some of
these these issues
um you know what what else can you say
about the upswelling awareness of some
of these cultural issues
how ha has it been a net positive has
has there been anything to write home
about in terms of awareness
in 2020 yeah so i think
what's been really interesting is that
we've seen huge
cultural um movements and protests
during the trump administration the
black lives matter protests that
happened this summer which i've already
mentioned
were have estimated to be one of the
biggest protest movements in the history
of the world um there were worldwide
protests that
is huge and it's it's hard to say you
know what would have happened had trump
not been president we can't prove that
that didn't happen but that did happen
you know in the last four years um
another similar
example of um a big protest movement
that happened which i do think as a
result of donald trump becoming
president was
the metoo movement and the women's
movement um
the first women's march happened right
around donald trump's inauguration it
was at the time and may still be
the biggest single day protest um in the
history of the country
um there have been multiple women's
marches since then and that was a
response to
the access hollywood tape that had come
out during the 2016 election
where donald trump made his infamous
remarks about grabbing
women without their permission and also
the multiple allegations of harassment
about trump that had come out during his
election so
that protest movement specifically came
um as a reaction to trump being elected
and then
also the metoo movement all of the
reporting that many journalists did
on harvey weinstein and then others
again was
a reaction to um having an alleged
sexual harasser in this really important
position of power so
i think um we don't know i don't know if
those things would have happened without
donald trump being a president i don't
know
i want to say there's a net positive or
negative but um
we have seen huge cultural movements and
as a reaction to this president and
those those have
changed our society in the world
so you mentioned blm me too these
movements being
backlashes to the president what about
the backlash
to black lives matter and me too um you
you touched on it
shortly on the emboldening of white
supremacist
groups and hate groups could you speak a
little bit more about it
yeah so um there has been an emboldening
of white supremacist groups and hate
groups and hate crimes there have been
lots of organizations who track
hate crimes um i one thing when i was
researching this i
found was that um you know hate groups
in 2018
surged seven percent specifically white
supremacist and white nationalist groups
um hate crimes have been up since donald
trump has been
president you can't i mean it's causal
um
but that's definitely um happening
there's also you know we've seen at the
protest counter protesters do show
up sometimes they're armed some of those
have turned into violent and sometimes
deadly clashes so
um anytime there's big cultural change
or cultural movements there are always
people who don't want that change
and so we are definitely seeing that
with black lives matter movement um with
the me too movement
there's been lots of talk of backlash um
i also when i was thinking about this
remembered
um you know a year after the metoo
movement um
exploded with harvey weinstein reporting
we had the confirmation of
brett kavanaugh to the supreme court
which was also wrapped up
in in the metoo movement and about
you know there were many discussions of
allegations of his own behavior
um and you know he did get a seat on the
court
so there's definitely like a balance on
a counterbalance thing that does happen
you know the pendulum swings but it's
swinging very quickly
under in our current modern world
absolutely um and we saw a little bit of
b-roll back there of of
amy coney barrett's um nomination with
donald trump
um and now today the the news came out
that she's been confirmed yesterday
solidifying a
conservative majority on the supreme
court for decades to come
um what sorts of concerns would
minorities and marginalized groups have
about that and
and what does this mean on the other
side for conservatives for for those on
the right
yeah so the the court's um you know the
supreme court has been at the center of
many
big cases that do um protect or erode
rights for certain groups i think
interestingly this year we saw
um a big supreme court case that was a
huge win for lgbtq workers
who were the supreme court recognized
them as protected under the civil rights
act which is the
law that protects against discrimination
against women and
people of color so um gay people are now
included in that
um and of course another big decision
was marriage equality that happened
under the obama administration so those
are the kinds of things that we can see
come out of the court
um i think going forward with a more
conservative
court there's a lot of talk about
abortion which is a big women's rights
issue
um we've written about this a bit
about how the court might go about
restricting
restricting abortion um under a new
court that's definitely i mean a concern
against advocates for abortion
um there's roe v wade which is the law
that says that
you know it's a federal protection for
abortion but there are also lots of
other ways that states try to
restrict abortion so that's definitely
something that no matter who
becomes the president the court
you know is separate of that so donald
trump will have already made his mark
on that world that makes sense
um there are a lot of other issues that
the scotus
will be privy to particularly
immigration um donald trump has
has made no secret of his his want to
to limit immigration um in terms of you
know the muslim ban
or the the the current policy with of of
family separation could you talk a
little bit more about that and how
that's a cultural wedge issue how that's
going to affect the 2020 election
yeah i think immigration which is is
actually you know i think
one of the reasons that many white
supremacist groups do support donald
trump is
is the administration's um stands on
immigration and who
is a citizen and who isn't and bringing
what you know who gets to come into the
country and who doesn't um yes since
again one of the very first things that
donald trump did
was the the muslim ban um and
it you know it went it was immediately
sued and it's been in a lot of legal
battles but i think is at the heart
of just like a change in our stance on
immigration and
immigration policies under donald trump
there has been a much more
um aggressive or more a stronger
use of ice under donald trump um
and i and i think joe biden
would have a different stance he has
said um
he you know had said he would go back to
more of what we saw
under president obama so you know
stopping a moratorium
on deportations um for 100 days and then
going back to the previous policy which
was
or sorry and then also you know only
deporting people who are
um convicted felonies so it's definitely
um
not as an aggressive stance on
immigration as donald trump has done
which i do agree has been a signature
um policy of this administration
and speaking of signature policies of
the administration a lot of these
um these actions
that affect marginalized groups have
been via executive order
um not necessarily through congress or
through the supreme court
um could you talk a little bit about
that and how it sort of
um could come undone under biden if he
were to do the same thing
you touched on it for us for a short
time though yeah so i think um
which we saw with donald trump early on
in his presidency was the use of
executive order and also undoing
executive orders that obama had
also used a lot of unders presidency um
as a way to get around a congress that
might not pass legislation that you want
um a lot the we've seen a lot of
executive orders in the last
few weeks having to do specifically with
for
diversity initiatives that the trump
administration doesn't like
um and so the you know that is a way to
get something done and get it done your
way but it does mean if a new
administration comes in it is um easier
to undo
and what's to stop um a
next administration from doing the same
thing it seems like this is becoming
just a political ping pong at a certain
point these cultural issues how
how does how is there any sort of
consistent change going to be enacted
either under
trump or biden it's a really good
question
i i can't predict the future um i think
you know to pass laws you need congress
um that's the reality of it i think um
yeah we'll just have to see how if if
biden or trump can
can actually pass laws in in
for these in these areas that we're
talking about
um and that kind of um trails into our
next question
and it shows how you know just the
importance but
our biggest question rebecca and you
know the question what the reason why
we're all here why is the 2020 race the
most important election ever
yeah for for the causes that we're
talking about i think for minority
groups for
um women for people of color for
immigrants for people who
you know for people of specific
religions the last four years have
really
seen a very different approach than the
previous eight years or even before that
and the question is what will the next
four years look like will it be a
continuation
of um you know emboldening of white
supremacists
or attempting to roll back certain
protections or
um you know less protection for abortion
you name it um so you know what will
former years of that look like and
will really solidify some of these
things that we're seeing happen
or you know will it be
going back to what we saw during the
obama administration which i think
these groups would have said there was
more
more progress more openness more um
inclusivity so
i i think it's it's a really important
moment um because four more years four
years is a long time and a new
administration
as we've seen with donald trump can
really change things
well that's a great place to close it
out um
you heard it here first people with less
than a week left before the 2020
election please go out and vote
um make your voices heard and tune in
next week for our final episode of the
most important election ever
rebecca greenfield i just wanted to
thank you again for joining us
and um rebecca if you had anything you
wanted to plug um from from your team
please go right ahead i'd love to uh
follow bloomberg news i don't have we do
a lot of great coverage we cover
you know we have a whole specific team
covering inequality and
diversity which i think is unique so we
have a lot of great stories you can
follow me on twitter at rz greenfield
and i tweet all my favorite stories from
all of our great reporters
awesome rebecca thanks for joining us on
the on the most important election ever
i'm eric white
this is bloomberg quick take bye-bye